en france il y a deux actrices qui sont
devenus des mythes sexuelle une c'est
probablement à cause de sa vie de ses
réflexions c'est brigitte bardot l'autre
à cause d'un film c'est mireille darc il
est avec nous aujourd'hui
miré quand on vous pose des questions
c'est rarement celles auxquelles vous
souhaiteriez répondre eh bien ici
aujourd'hui d'un côté jardin ça va être
beaucoup plus simple puisque c'est vous
qui allez vous poser les questions
auxquelles vous allez répondre
vous allez avoir à peu près un quart
d'heure pour jouer à ce nouveau jeu du
mensonge et de la vérité dans lequel je
ne serais pas si vous le voulez bien
votre interviewer mais en quelque sorte
votre interlocuteur oui c'est assez
difficile pour moi parce que au fond
j'aime bien les questions parce que je
peux me retrancher derrière je peux vous
cacher je peux dire ce que j'ai envie
bien sûr j'ai préparé un peu mon
questionnaire bien sûr je suis inquiète
pas plus tout à fait tout le monde bien
alors est ce que la vie me passionne je
dois dire au départ que je suis un être
optimiste mais optimiste bonheur je veux
dire au bonheur absolu pour moi est
toujours du soleil
quoi qu'il arrive il ya toujours une
possibilité de récupérer tout ça veut
dire que vous ne vous ennuyez jamais
jamais et puis je ne perds jamais
confiance et puis
et puis j'abandonne pas je m'accroche je
suis un taureau je suis du signe du
taureau je suis un taureau qui
m'accroche vous êtes une dure ces maps
ou ça que j'ai pas mal c'est pour ça que
je souffre pas c'est pas pour ça que je
n'ai pas de sensibilité pas du tout mais
je ne veux pas me laisser bouffer par la
vie par justement par le péril par la
peur par l' angoisse
voilà après je voudrais savoir si si les
arbres me fascine important des ordres à
cette énorme c'était épouvantable parce
que il y aille à ses racines qui sont là
ya cette masse au dessus de vous à la
campagne où j'habite
j'ai une allée de s'être et tous les
printemps je vois les pouces que font
ces arbres et ses pouces représentent à
peu près à deux centimètres par an et
quand je me dis que bon si j'ai de la
chance je vais vivre 10 ans 70 ans c'est
à dire que ça va représenter à peu près
d'un mètre
je sais pas c'est quelque chose pour moi
de
de rassurant peut-être et en même temps
de gigantesques enfin j'ai envie je
rends vide de soigner ces arbres de leur
expliquer des choses de leur raconter
des choses je rendis qui se souviennent
de moi j'ai envie qu'il faut planté des
eucalyptus ça pousse très vite
oui mais oui mais j'aime bien les arbres
qui sont déjà là qu'ils étaient avant
moi bien sûr chacun dans la vie à un
arbre est ce que vous n'avez plus
particulièrement 1 1 qui est à vous oui
il ya un an que j'ai sauvée c'est un
noyer je les sauver de la sécheresse il
était en train de mourir
donc je voulais suis là j'ai une petite
tendresse particulière pour les biens à
coeur y'a qu'à noyer dans cette
propriété est depuis que je m'en suis
occupé depuis que je les sauver il a
doublé
prosper les gros des superbes voilà
ensuite pourquoi
où que je sois je sais où se trouve le
nord je sais vous savez oui je peux me
trouver dans n'importe quelle ville dans
n'importe quel endroit la nuit comme le
jour
je sais où se trouve le nord ouais une
explication relevé je pense je crois que
dans une vie antérieure
j'ai dû être oiseau mes oiseaux
migrateurs je voudrais plus vu comme une
chatte avec le connaissais peu je
l'étais traités par la suite eu
plusieurs vies antérieures et bien sûr
automatiquement avant d'être un être
humain et on a passé on passe des
différentes étapes et le nom de
métempsychose vous aimez je trouve très
beau c'est pour voilà alors j'ai dû être
noises aux migrateurs
celui d'aller sur les ordres j'ai des
ronds à la campagne
voici qui chaque année reviennent chez
moi ça c'est aussi une explication que
j'arrive pas à comprendre comment ces
bêtes qui s'en vont reviennent tous les
ans au même endroit
si vous avez été reçu à l'espace énorme
oui mais l'explication mais pas rester
dans ma tête et j'ai envie de parler de
toulon où je suis né et où j'ai passé 19
ans de ma vie mon enfance et mon
adolescence n'a pas du tout je veux
petit vous n'aimez pas votre adolescence
non c'est un trou noir pour moi personne
m'a donné envie d'exister à cette époque
là donc si vous voulez toulon représente
ça et à part mes parents qui vivent
toujours
et un ami qui est le maire de la ville
que j'aime beaucoup aussi
je dirais que c'est une ville pour moi
qui correspond à rien et cette envie de
vivre dont vous avez parlé des bus et
elle vient de
elle vient de ce trou noir peut-être
peut-être justement parce que ce manque
d'adolescence manque de souvenirs ce
manque de ce manque de chaleur
finalement peut-être c'est ça
parlez-nous de quelque chose de plus
agréable
alors est ce que j'ai envie de parler
d'alain devant sûrement oui ça arrive
vraiment beaucoup
alors elle a de longs quand ils vous
présentent je prends dit que vous êtes
sa femme et vous quand vous le présentez
vous présenter comment tu mon fiancé
je suis sa promise
oui je voudrais parler d'alain delon
parce que pour moi c'est un être hors du
commun avec avec des dimensions
différentes avec une morale complètement
à lui avec je veux dire c'est un
visionnaire pour moi c'est quelqu'un qui
qui voit les choses avec une acuité
rapide
c'est quelqu'un aussi qu'à sens des
responsabilités comme je connais peu
d'être au monde qu'ils ont c'est un chef
de famille aussi je veux dire avec sa
place le seigneur mais dans le seigneur
dans le bon sens du terme c'est à dire
que je dire il protège sa couvée protège
sa maison il
il est pas là pour parader il est là
justement pour assumer et ça c'est une
chose si vous voulez que on trouve
rarement maintenant chez les aides c'est
à dire qu'ils les êtres ne donne plus de
valeur aux choses et lui est un être qui
donne de la valeur à chaque chose c'est
pas parce qu'ils cherchent à voir la
première place à la maison que me
cherche à la voir dans l'ensemble dans
son métier ou dans ses activités c'est
un perfectionniste de toute façon donc
je pense que c'est ça mais je pense que
ça va plus loin je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui est ancré en lui
je pense que c'est un être qui aurait pu
vivre il ya quelques quelques siècles et
qui aurait eu une vie comme ça de
guerriers de
deux chefs et en même temps c'est
quelqu'un de tellement disponible est
tellement tendre que je crois que peu de
gens le connaissent comme ça d'un être
sûr qu'il faut jamais s'arrêter sur le
petit détail c'est quelqu'un qu'il faut
voir sur un plan sur sur l'ensemble de
sa vie sur ses sentiments sur une durée
de temps mais jamais sur un moment
qu'elle est sa faiblesse
c'est de croire de croire aux êtres
après le portrait d'alain delon est ce
que vous avez un autre portrait affaires
non sa fouille à face dans un autre sens
oui qui m'a le plus aidé
intellectuellement
alors je pense que c'est je pense que
c'est michel audiard oui oui c'est assez
curieux peut-être est-ce que bon michel
m'a aidée si vous voulez à me à me
trouver au fond soudain un délire verbal
sous une sous des personnages très fort
fantoches il m'a permis si vous voulez
d'avoir le sens de la curiosité car
c'est un être au fond très observateur
très tendre très très présents aussi est
qui qui m'a donné ce sens si vous voulez
de ne pas prendre les choses trop au
sérieux aussi de pas s'arrêter à la à la
chose qui vous accroche b2 de passer
dessus d'aller plus loin de de continuer
de
de prendre des choses un petit peu plus
avec du recul et ça je lui dois beaucoup
parce que justement il m'a permis de
m'ouvrir à la vie de mme ouvrirait aux
choses en face c'est un petit peu la
mafia vous parlez toujours les uns des
autres en disant plus grand bien comme
ça vous connaissez ma famille j'aimerais
mieux que ma famille oui il ya un autre
homme de qui j'ai envie de parler aussi
ce que j'ai en pas envie de parler de
georges lautner oui j'ai fait quatorze
films avec lui c'est quand même énorme
j'ai passé dix ans quatorze films à
raison de deux mois par film donc vous
êtes un héron et c'est un gros nounours
ah oui oui c'est un gros nounours c'est
vrai avec des faiblesses c'est vrai pour
moi si vous voulez un manque d'ambition
ce metteur en scène pour moi qui dois
être un des premiers il l'est
certainement il l'est mais ils devraient
ils devraient être en tête et c'est son
côté un peu sentimental c'est son côté
un peu copla quand il a essayé d'avoir
de l'ambition sera pas tout à fait pas
marcher aussi bien pourquoi n'en d'un
pourri non c'est moi là alors je suis
plus un
pensez à quoi non mais je pense qu'il a
souvent eu des envies de prendre
d'autres voies galia ce n'est pas bien
assise légale ya sept ans plein c'est en
plein dans la voix eh ben voilà
moi je vous cite des filles pas que je
connais bien d'accord alors après c'est
une autre question que j'ai envie de me
poser c'est là un peu plus sérieuse
pourquoi l'information m'agace elle
parce que je pense que l'information va
trop loin et que sous le couvert de la
liberté de la presse
on va trop vite et trop loin auprès des
gens on leur explique trop de choses on
rentre dans les détails on n'a pas
toujours affaire à des gens qui qui ont
un sens
certains des choses et je pense qu'on
fait beaucoup de mal on leur donne des
idées on les pousse on explique comment
on fait un hold up
comment certaines femmes se sont fait
violer dans des bois je trouve ça
épouvantable c'est peut-être pas parce
qu'on donne trop d'informations mais
alors parce qu'on ne donne pas une
information d'une manière responsable
oui mais justement c'est vrai ça c'est
exact mais alors pourquoi donner autant
d'importance à certaines choses pourquoi
met-on une dame en première page d'un
journal important alors qu'elles sortent
de prison et qu'elle vient de perdre son
mari et on la met en première page en
train de faire de la publicité
sam je suis scandalisé parce que vous
avez envie de créer un journal au nom je
me battrai trop basse et bien justement
non je serai je dis je pense que les
gens aiment bien les commérages et moi
je les aime pas je n'aime pas du tout
sûr j'en souffre énormément
oui monsieur attention que huit minutes
alors je voudrais aussi savoir quand
j'ai commencé à vivre
j'ai commencé à vivre le jour où on m'a
regardé oui c'est à dire le jour j'ai
commencé à exister et vous continuez a
bien existé depuis oui mais ce sont les
hommes qui vous en gardez donc vous
existez par les hommes complètement et
je n'aime que les hommes de toute façon
les rapports avec les hommes sont plus
faciles beaucoup plus direct beaucoup
plus facile qu'au moins médiocre
beaucoup moins mais ce cas aussi mais
c'est une opinion qui qui ne touche que
moi i'm here est important près d'ypres
a dit moi que vous n'avez vu que les
hommes jeunes est localisable
c'est vrai et c'est grâce à eux que vous
avez travaillé que voulez vous c'est eux
qui ont fait mal c'est à cause du rejet
exister c'est à cause bien continuer à
vivre
[Musique]